hey everyone bandit here you know what i
hate mosquitoes ticks male anglerfish
you know things that leech the life out
of other things in order to stay alive
parasites if you will and normally that
means that i would say i hate metroids
from the appropriately named metroid
franchise as well but now that i've
beaten metro dread i'm conflicted
because samus is spoiler alert
a metroid like straight up full on suck
the life out of anything she touches 100
parasitic metroid with a kick-ass suit
to boot jokes aside though the ending of
metroid dread was truly something to
behold even if it felt a bit rushed but
as a fan of samus and the franchise as a
whole it left me wondering what's next
after metroid 5. can there be a next
have all of the enemies of samus aaron
and humanity itself been eradicated from
every corner of the known universe at
this point well to be frank no i don't
think so actually i think samus's
biggest adventure and most deadly foe is
yet to come but let me explain why i
think that ask yourself a question as of
the ending of metroid 5 also known as
metroid dread how many loose ends or
potential storylines are still left
unanswered in the franchise the unknown
genocidal chozo warrior known as
ravenbeak aka samus's adopted father
that we got to see in the secret ending
of samus returns which was perhaps
previously the biggest loose end of all
of the games was completely covered in
this game which in turn also explained
why the chozo have a notable lack of
existence in most of the games aside
from that though we do have the huge
unanswered question of why exactly the
galactic federation was quite blatantly
trying to reproduce metroid's in metroid
fusion aka metroid 4 and why they wanted
the deadly sax kept alive for study but
both of these questions could be chalked
up easily to the federation just simply
trying to obtain the greatest weapons in
the known universe in order to keep the
peace you know through fear and violence
diplomacy although that also begs the
question of whether or not the
federation holds samus accountable for
the destruction of the research station
which had all of their metroid research
and whatever else they had going on
inside in the events of metroid fusion
if you'll recall samus clearly acts
against the federation's orders when she
you know sends the research station into
the planet sr-388 and blows them both to
kingdom come but again since there has
been no blowback that we know of from
the federation by the events of metroid
5 it can be assumed that samus was able
to convince the federation of her
reasons for disobedience and now all is
well and good and peachy between the two
parties so really there aren't any
unanswered loose ends as far as the 2d
metroid games before dread are concerned
there is however a glaring loose end
that happens at the current end of the
metroid prime series though which takes
place in its entirety between the 2d
games metroid 1 and 2. for those in the
know you'll recall that at the end of
metroid prime 3 corruption samus is
shown being followed by the mysterious
bounty hunter psylux into deep space the
story then continues in metroid prime
federation force which everyone bought
and played when at the end of that game
we're shown a pov perspective of psylux
as the mystery dude stumbles upon an
infant metroid obviously this has huge
implications but as far as whether it
will affect the story of metroid 6 i
personally find it unlikely since we
have metroid prime 4 in the works
allegedly i'm about 50 convinced we all
hallucinated it but should metroid prime
4 ever actually release we can only
assume that it would take place after
metroid prime federation force anyway my
point with all of this is that no matter
what we look at at which point in the
series everything that could be a
potential storyline in the franchise
leading up to metroid dread is either
explainable or has another outlet coming
that we know isn't going to be metroid
6. so that leaves us with only one
option is there anything left unanswered
in metroid dread itself that could lead
to another game based off of dread well
my friends i am here to tell you that
absolutely yes there is recall with me
if you will the events of the end of the
game samus has to travel to the second
to final area on the surface of zdr
called hanubia where her ship is only
adam tells her that she can't leave just
yet she's got to face ravenbeak because
if she doesn't kill him or at least try
to kill him he's just gonna escape and
do the same thing somewhere else right
as you traverse around the area you even
see some clearly active ships hovering
in the distance so you're thinking to
yourself okay yeah i see that he might
escape so samus does exactly what adam
said to do and finds this extremely cool
thrown seat and flying sphere thing and
travels upwards above the surface of
ziti are two raven beaks levitating
fortress called iturash and it is here
that ravenbeek reveals that he was adam
the whole time and that samus is
essentially his dna shared daughter and
then has the life sucked out of him by
his aforementioned daughter not only
does daddy's girl suck the life force
metroid style out of her old man she
also does this to the entire flying
fortress of aitorash crashing the whole
system into hanubia on the surface of
zdr but alas ravenbeak was hurt but not
killed and after both he and his little
girl get up and see that each other is
still alive an ex-parasite takes control
of ravenbeak's body turning him into
crane actually but then getting killed
for good by metroid samus and then the
planet starts to blow up for some reason
probably because of iturosh crashing
into the planet like the space research
lab in metroid fusion anyway metroid
samus has to book it out of there but
here at the very end of the game is
where the biggest loose end happens and
it's simultaneously right in front of us
as well as being extremely missable i
mean even i missed it the first time i
was playing remember the ships i
mentioned earlier that were turned on
and hovering in the background of
hanubia well if you pay attention to the
background while getting the hell out of
dodge as metroid samus you can see that
those ships are no longer there now keep
in mind that even though some things in
hanubia have been affected by the crash
of aitorash structurally most of it is
exactly the same and hasn't been
destroyed or even hurt yet including the
ship bays that we can see in the
background where the ships were docked
previously this means that the ships
couldn't have received any damage and
been knocked out of the sky for my
korush's fault because nothing around
them has been hurt there's only one
possibility for why these ships are
missing they've been flown away prior to
the planet's destruction but it gets
worse do you remember what was on the
planet at the time of itoresh's descent
the only thing that could have possessed
the knowledge to operate what we can
only assume are chozo ships well that
would be the mock and tribe of the chozo
that had initially followed their leader
ravenbeek to the planet before being
completely possessed by the ex-parasite
that's right remember that it was
revealed to us that ravenbeak and quiet
robe were the last two chozo in known
existence to not be possessed by the x
that's why ravenbeak had quarantined all
of his fellow chozo warriors in elune
which samus unknowingly released to the
rest of the planet which we know because
after this literally every organism on
the planet is possessed by x but through
the events of the game we see quiet row
become infected then sacrifice himself
for samus at the very end and of course
we see raven beak become infected but
then get obliterated immediately by
metroid samus that means that the only
way those chozo ships could move from
the background is if they were flown
away by the ex-possessed chozo warriors
you know this was a deliberate detail
put in the game that in my opinion was
meant to tease samus's next adventure
which we can only assume will be metroid
6. and like i said now that the x
parasite not only has survived yet
another destruction attempt but also has
wings with which to fly anywhere they
want to in the galaxy there's no telling
how fast how far or how badly the x will
spread but one thing's per certain they
literally have limitless potential like
never before meaning there could be an
infinite number of x parasites by the
time the next game takes place and with
their only predator the metroid's being
completely extinct except for samus
aaron the last metroid in existence well
it seems to me that the ultimate
showdown between the metroid species and
the infinite x parasite has yet to
happen and who knows maybe it will end
with the destruction of both parasitic
species once and for all but this is all
just my theory what do you guys think
could it be that the ex-parasite was
responsible for flying the mysterious
chozo ships away at the end of metroid
dread or did a game developer just
forget to put him back in there at the
end of the game let me know in the
comments below also thank you so much
for watching please consider liking this
video if you liked the video to get
metroid spread around on youtube because
samus deserves it and subscribe to the
channel for so many more interesting
gaming videos to come that will knock
your socks off huge thanks as always to
my fantastic bandit crew who make my day
every day that's all i've got for this
one so as always i hope you have a
wonderful rest of your day this is mask
nintendo abandoned looking forward to
seeing you next time and signing out
[Music]
you